in the world of astronomy we have some
very impressive telescopes they work by
reflecting light of a large mirror and
into the camera all of our best
telescopes work this way and it makes
them great at collecting images but
mirrors also scatter light making it
hard to see dim regions this lost light
means we can only see the reasonably
bright objects another kind of telescope
our refractor uses lenses instead of
mirrors in fact a camera lens does a
very similar thing and although it is a
lot smaller it can see very dim objects
that the larger telescopes miss because
the lenses don't scatter as much light
that's where I come in the huntsmen
array I'm going to be pointed at some
nearby galaxies to see what I can find
I can't wait to see what's hiding like
dwarf galaxies or non faint structures
anything I find will help my science
team to understand how our universe came
to be all this using commercial Canon
lenses join me to unravel the secrets
and complexities of a world beyond our
own